beaucoup en rêvent revivre la venue d'un
club de renommée internationale à
orléans pour un match de coupe comme en
décembre dernier face au paris saint
germain le stade de la source plein à
craquer 9000 spectateurs enflammé venus
de toute la région de la france entière
supporter les jaune et rouge face à une
équipe de ligue 1 eh bien ce ne sera pas
pour cette fois
à la fin du mois lui est so se déplacera
à rennes en quarts de finale de la coupe
de france le tirage nous met dans
l'obligation de de faire un vrai vrai
vrai exploit d'aller se qualifier à
rennes pour partager les demi-finales
qui serait encore plus historique à
domicile lors du prochain tour le stade
rennais ici en blanc actuel 10e de ligue
1 l'une des cinq grosses équipes du
championnat budget et ambition
confondues des joueurs qui évoluent tant
europa league et pour faire simple du
lourd ils sont elles sont vraiment très
bien et ils jouent bien ils ont des
attaquants qui vont vite une défense qui
était imperméable donc c'est une belle
équipe on titille un petit peu le le
très haut niveau et donc voilà c'est
toujours encourageant et d'apprentissage
le très haut niveau le dernier club de
ligue 2 encore en coupe de france le
titille déjà depuis plusieurs mois après
avoir battu reims et mais sur leur
pelouse respectives
le supplément d'âme de la outsiders fera
peut-être une nouvelle fois la
différence